[Musique]
après un moratoire de 14 ans l'islande a
repris depuis hier la chasse à la
baleine officiellement l'activité est
mené à des fins scientifiques
pour l'instant les baleiniers sont
rentrés bredouilles mais les
associations écologistes restent très
mobilisés à l'exemple de greenpeace qui
a décidé d'envoyer sur place le rainbow
warrior laetitia funchal gérard
elles nageaient sans crainte depuis 14
ans protégé par un moratoire
international
après le japon et la norvège l'islande
et le troisième pays à autoriser la
chasse à la baleine la démarche est
officiellement scientifique il s'agit
d'observer leur régime alimentaire
d'estimer les réserves de poissons une
argumentation qui ne convainc pas
greenpeace
il n'y a absolument pas besoin de tuer
des cétacés pour les étudier
l'objectif explicite du ministère de la
pêche puisque c'est sur c'est sur son
site internet c'est de relancer la
chasse commerciale dès 2006 l'islande
s'est fixée un maximum de 500 prises
pour les deux ans à venir cette pêche
concerne le petit rorqual une espèce
rarement pêcher la baleine bleue elle a
déjà disparu à 90% alors cette décision
ne réjouit pas les professionnels du
tourisme
je suis inquiet oui inquiets de voir
comment cette reprise de la chasse
affecté notre activité d'observation des
baleines qui fait venir beaucoup de
touristes en islande
les trois navires partis en mer cette
nuit sont rentrés bredouilles
les touristes trop nombreux avaient fait
fuir les cétacés
[Musique]